we started working with Cindy Ruskin who
had written was working on a coffee
table book about the quilt and she was
collecting stories of people who had
sewn panels and the people that they
were remembering and we started trying
to figure out how to make a movie out of
a quilt and it you know watching it it
now it seems to me this is the structure
is kind of inevitable this approach to
find a few stories in the in the quilt
and and flush them out but it took us a
long time to get to that point
I remember we talked at one point about
making a hundred short films like making
a film version of a quilt where each
each each like one or two minute film
would be a different style or some
animated some dramatic some documentary
and we played with that idea for a while
and we really couldn't figure out how we
would how we would be able to sustain
any kind of narrative over the course of
and there's such an emotional weight to
the way it's laid out in the film itself
how did you find these stories of these
five subjects we went back to San
Francisco and started reading letters
that were coming in with the panels so
at that point I think there were about
2000 panels which means 2,000 letters
and Geoffrey Cindy and I read every
every one of those letters and from
those 2000 we narrowed it down to about
200 that we actually wanted to try and
speak with and we did phone interviews
with about that many and then did pre
video pre interviews with probably about
50 or 75 in the end two people came from
that process
Tracy Torre and the Mandel's Sally
Perryman was a reader at one of the
unfoldings and I went up and introduced
myself Vito was a good friend of ours
Sarah and Tom were also people we knew
so
you know we knew we wanted to have this
representation and essentially found the
people we felt best represented each of
those you know represented the different
groups that were being affected by
hiv/aids biodiversity yep I just wanted
to say one more thing about Tracy when
Tracy Torre the navy commander we read
his letter and of course we were blown
away by that and Cindy had a phone
conversation with them and after after
she got off the phone he called back
immediately and said I don't have much
time I'm coming to San Francisco this
weekend and I'm gonna make my own panel
and you're welcome to fill me so at that
point we didn't have any funding but we
did film him at the becks motel which
was a block away from the name's project
building and he made its own panel and
if you look closely at the panel I think
one of his children signs it so when you
get a chance to to look at it outside
just recently we had never had any
contact with his family but recently his
daughter looked us up on Facebook so
we're now in touch with Tracy's daughter
and have you had any chance to have any
updates from any of the other panel
makers I know when like 2004 you were
able to find out what happened how Sally
is doing but have you yeah we were in
touch with Sally was a 2004 it was
something like this about 15 years ago
and she was doing great she was she was
working in public health in New York she
was my grandma yeah and we've lost touch
with the Mandel's if if anybody has any
contact information we would love to
we'd love to know about it Sarah
I just spoke with Sarah Lou enstein is
doing great she's still very sporty
she's the general manager of a bowling
alley in Silicon Valley
jessica is 35 and married and has seven
month-old boy Vito of course died the
year the film came out and when he was
in the hospital dying I flew with the
Oscar
so the Oscar was with him in his last
moments and he bequeathed his life's
work the celluloid closet to Geoffrey
and I we made that film in 95